archivos nacionales lleva más de un año
en comunicación cuando un autor tratando
de que el ex presidente devuelva
documentos confidenciales que se llevó
de la casa blanca a la mansión en mara
lago y no ha querido devolver una de las
peticiones más grandes que archivos
nacionales le hizo el ex presidente fue
en enero 250 documentos clasificados
como confidenciales algo que prendió las
alarmas en el departamento de justicia y
llevó al allanamiento que hizo
recientemente el fbi en mar al lago
según lo dicen fuentes cercanas al caso
al 'new york times' en total el gobierno
ha recuperado más de 300 documentos
clasificados desde que trump dejó la
casa blanca inicialmente son devolvió
algunos documentos en enero de este año
después su equipo legal devolvió otros
documentos en junio y recientemente tras
el allanamiento de su casa en la florida
se recuperaron otros documentos esta
información se conoce justo después de
que trump haya demandado al gobierno
para que suspenda la revisión de los
documentos confiscados que está haciendo
el departamento de justicia y que
podrían ser prueba del grado de
confidencialidad
los documentos que estaba tratando de
esconder el ex presidente viene también
justo antes esta información de que los
medios de comunicación esperan
precisamente este jueves más información
sobre los detalles de la información que
recuperó los documentos clasificados que
recuperó el fbi en mar al ajo